[Music]
all right and we are live
iron law podcast Lords a gaming dotnet I
am Laura kognito and it was a fine
gentlemen in the room today I'm Andrew
from mass creation and we're talking
showcasing [ __ ] today right so we look
at that Shing and off the top I love the
art style looks really cool for those
who don't know what is Shing about give
us the whole premise about the game some
Shing is a game about slashing demons to
pieces with your friends we're trying to
capture the spirit of old-school beat em
ups that you just put in when you have
some friends over and a lot of our
design is centered around the idea that
we want you to have fun instantly with
your friends with know like obstacles so
smaller team again I'm seeing a little
four player co-op action that looks
fantastic
loving the art style so tell me about
like the abilities of the characters
things like that what are the things you
can do in shrinker the game looks fun
alright so the first thing we usually
people realize is that we have a
unconventional control scheme because
you control your character your attacks
with the right analog stick there are
gestures you might on the right analog
stick translate into specific attacks so
if you flick for example like forward
left
you know the clip if you hold up you
uppercut the uppercut the enemy and
follow it you can dispense how circles
and stuff like that so a lot of analog
right analog control yes basically this
is the main mapping and we have like a
free-flowing combo system so you can you
can
mix and match different kind of combos
into a real attacks combat attacks with
your friends
the basic premise was that we wanted it
to be very robust but very very simple
to understand okay most people just
experiment with the stick for a moment
and then they do like crazy
so we can get real complex with the
combos okay
we like that we like that no again I'm
noticing four player so seamless drop in
and drop out for cooperative play yes
definitely you can drop in at any time
and the way we the game changes more
people are is the more complex enemies
attacks that will work very well in
crowds like Aria attacks or they they
use different attacks the more people
they are so the game gets harder without
it getting grind there what's more at
all times you have four four characters
available they have different separate
health bars okay so if you're playing
alone you have like four lives and if
you're playing with your friends
everyone's in there oh absolutely any
time actually so if you get also you can
okay Wow if you get both of a character
you can just switch how many characters
totally are in the game four characters
in the game and they have pretty similar
abilities because we don't there are two
reason the first we wanted you to be
able to switch to any of them others at
any time because they do work us
different lives and we wanted to avoid
the situation where people have clear
favorite or character they dislike and
they get stuck so what is going on right
now
the game is pretty basic with this story
the main truline reason because it's
just there was an artifact that's very
important for people and it got stolen
but stories is basic because we wanted
to focus on the characters and their
interactions so basic story so it's more
character focus you would say okay cool
so as far as level design engine what do
we use in a game looks bright it looks
very colorful you don't say what engine
are we're using right now so this is you
anything that's whipped into shape
salute to weapon unity in the shape I
said salute to you guys whipping unity
into shape really bad red but it's a
powerful engine that you can do some
cool stuff with and because of that we
put the game on all the platforms
simultaneously unless something we're
doing simultaneous platform launch I
will be doing okay okay cool and also I
will announce we have the next
generation consoles coming as well will
we be porting will be also assisting
those consoles and I'm sorry I didn't
get this fine gentleman's name in the
realm nice nice so tell us your
perspective of what do you like most
about shake what do you think
Shing bring that's different that you
love about the game basically I love the
that the control scheme the analog stick
really works and people love it
because that was the most scary part
when developing Shing we we really
didn't know if the if you're scared that
analog controller yeah yeah I know we
already have some some some some people
telling us during the beta that the
right analog stick just went off so
yeah it's very heavy on the ride and if
you have an old old xbox 360 controller
yeah it might not that level of
sensitivity might not be there will you
do what you need
yes so this is Pacific and I love the
characters I love the design that our
approach to Oni demons demons and stuff
like that so yeah for me she is a
basically a drink I'm tryna old-school
beat them up that's what we come from
the old school the beat'em ups you know
the four players the Streets of Rage the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles you know
that these are games that's a big
project you hear that developers if you
want to make a sequel to the streets
Eddy publish you're listening please
shake the team they already know that
this looks a piercing to Greg and he'll
just go change it if you're listening so
Lord Lord gene any questions how you
feeling about the game so you feeling
the analog control is it feel intuitive
to you getting the combos out yeah
absolutely
it reminds me almost like an older NBA
game where you would use like this stick
to have more advanced controls or maybe
even like Madden how you would use the
thumb stick as opposed to pressing the
buttons when the controls got more
advanced you can definitely feel like
you have full control over the sword and
where it goes so now as far as levels
level design how many levels are we
looking at right now for sure so we're
looking at seven levels but levels are
pretty complex and each one ends with a
set piece pause
and this should add up to about 6-7
hours for one playthrough okay but in
addition to that we have like family we
call all rooms some like we have some
story and some died like in the game but
if you think with your friends more
often than not you do not have time you
can go in so we could skip just we'll
pass them by and don't talk to people
okay same goes for challenge rooms have
additional like combat challenge that
checks how well you know the system and
there's also they are also optional and
more one more thing is every level can
be mastered so I can fit in with enough
cool moves or we found thinking damage
and this is the way we are not spin
scorecards right alright cool so for
these challenge modes that we're talking
about will we have like achievements and
trophies to reward the player that is
that's going and enduring these type of
challenge goals yes we will have a lot
of time then yeah we have that we're
implementing right now that the game
will reward you with a tiny achievement
every time you do something cool so like
council like um I real a combo and to
catch the enemy for it drops the ground
or parry a grenade and then kick someone
into the explosion you said Perry yeah
we did you hide now moves
alright so tell us about the parry
system so we wanted to have a robust
defensive move set as well because I
sell me the maps were really simple like
you image the enemy and as soon as you
entered the documents you have to attack
or you have to get hit right this didn't
theoretical so we and it's dodges that
so dashes that give you her eyes frames
and the blocks and Paris first two
cancels out
we did more complex enemies sorry how do
the enemies combat that if you let
Parian and you're dodging how do the
enemies compare so the enemies do much
more than just running up to and
function in the face we have some
enemies that throw grenades or they have
shields that you need to hit specific
parts of the body or we have like a
support unit but we have like a fencer
enemy that will block your attacks so we
need to really mix it up so he just
can't keep up okay and then you can just
party his weapon
nice lovingness that's that no listen
you you really open my mind because
honestly I thought it was just simple
hack and slash I had no idea we had
Perry's counters the enemies can do the
same there's a lot deeper than you you
guys are leaving on
yeah well the basic idea like was we
would love to beat them up spots we also
loved something like spectacle finder so
I saw them in my cries I wanted to put
some of it into the game so you can
you can uppercut the enemy into the air
and do a crazy combo and in Council and
so we wanted to have a lot of this
spectacular in the game and this is
what's one of the reasons why we came up
with the controls because you need a lot
of moves to not a little bit more
freedom you're not as restrictive with
your friends you just give them a
controller and if what else can be the
map you will just say this is punch to
say yeah that's it and we want you to
keep it like that so like this is analog
stick this is a dog this is junk this is
blow I love when I'm hearing now forest
development how far you guys in
development and how far out from release
so we are on the last stretch we are
aiming for q2 so the second quarter this
year this year the core is done we're
just pumping out levels and enemies by
now hopefully and the last question I
gotta ask just from silly does the name
the Shing what's the significance of the
name well I hope the whole game the
whole philosophy of the game is just
cool and simple it's just we just go
with swords clashing swords thought
living discovers like I love it okay I
got you guys dude this is looking
awesome
three machines Shing in the realm for
play looks like cooperative play classic
beat them up with a twist a lot of
defensive moves a lot of cool things
we're super excited about this we can't
wait to get in guys get close to release
you heard here for Jean is it I Lord
approve
Lord Gena proves so I mean I'm in you
heard it here first
I'm gonna podcast Lourdes the gaming
down that Shing y'all be on the lookout
for this one
[Music]